crumble came in and is crushing with
cookies I think there's a principle
limiting variety 506 cookies are new
every week you know what hasn't done
that yet is ice cream stores I haven't
seen ice cream stores switched their all
of their flavors except for just like
chocolate and vanilla every week they
don't do that so there's probably an ice
cream store like disrupter who could
make that switch we ordered the crumble
cookies just because we're like let's
try these ones with that variety extend
your LTV how can we just create
consistently rotating new flavors they
also know that the more options you give
someone the more total Food they'll eat
and if anything about total food as like
a proxy for LTV the more things they'll
consume Oreos figured that out it was
like okay well we'll just put
limited flavors every weekend and so we
were like oh let's see what carrot cake
Oreos taste like